you look good how are you feeling never
been better yeah yeah tonight because I
know you know he was one of the first
people at the hospital to see you he's
always been there for you yeah the world
I learned someone from off the court on
the court everything kind of translates
and life is beautiful yeah what's next
for you Lamar um get back on the court
are you gonna try and play again yeah I
still got it you look like you could
still play yeah I could okay let me ask
you this there are certain websites that
will follow you around and put up
pictures and post up which we understand
is not always true how do you deal with
that and handle that on the ingre stuff
especially is so much speculative only a
few people know the truth and I just
keep that close to my heart yeah yeah
Chloe says she's gonna go forward with
the divorce are you okay with that um
we're gonna talk everything is on this
discussion
we told about anything I mean we've been
through a lot so they won't ever stop
so many people out there praying for you
Heidi have you had a chance to connect
with some of the fans and just thank
them I'll take this time to do that
right now I just like to say thanks to
everybody that was praying for me close
to my heart research